alors que la propagation de la cobi 19
fait rage et que le gouvernement a
annoncé le contournement de nouveaux
départements il s'agit de la nièvre du
rhône et de l'aube
la situation en france devient de plus
en plus compliqué et de nouvelles
mesures pourraient s'imposer il est
apparu indispensable d'amplifier les
mesures de protection si les
rassemblements à l'extérieur sont déjà
très limité le télétravail très répandue
les rassemblements chez les particuliers
désormais interdits un espace de
propagation du virus pourrait rester à
explorer les écoles de plus en plus de
classes sont fermées en raison de quatre
variants en début de semaine le ministre
de l'éducation jean michel blanquer
c'est semble-t-il pris les pieds dans le
tapis quand au taux d'incidence dans les
écoles ça fait 5 pour mille deux cents 0
5% ça fait 5 pour mille cinq cent pour
cent mille aujourd'hui la situation
paraît hors de contrôle et le président
de la république pourrait décider de
suivre la belgique hier s'est résolu à
fermer à son tour ces établissements
scolaires cela va des écolos commerce en
passant par les salons de coiffure une
décision qui inquiète puisqu'elle
pourrait à nouveau retardé les
programmes scolaires
alors faut-il fermer les écoles de toute
urgence alors faut-il fermer les écoles
de toute violence et la grosse question
du jour oui non vous avez un petit point
car bien entendu nous ont rejoint jimmy
mohamed mon chéri mon ami comment savoir
m'ont dit merci les pta fabrice di vizio
avocat qui est là merci ça va fabrice
abrapa dossier aujourd'hui l'atout de
soutien sont elles un style moderne
porte parole de la république hommage
merci mode
merci d'état jean messia merci toujours
un bien costumés mais voilà merci d'être
là également et il n'ya se gagnent moix
quitte avec une paire cia nous qui sera
donc btp aussi tout à leur double cacher
aujourd'hui pour lui à dit belle kate
avec mercy souvient on m'a dit on m'a
mis sur le papillon mais mère de fanny
trêve nerfs écoutez on a décidé que
j'étais simplement mère de famille donc
on va jouer le rôle de la mère a fait
quoi sous en ce moment je travaille dans
l'immobilier alors oui je suis
journaliste qui mène à tout comme on ne
sait pas exactement pas regardé voilà la
preuve ici pour vous souvenez il faut
fermer les écoles travaux oui tout à
fait pourquoi ce qui se passait a fait
avait écouté je vais vous livrer
quelques témoignages que j'ai pu
recueillir auprès des copines
aujourd'hui oui j'espère qu'elles sont
devant leur poste parce que j'ai promis
de ramener leurs paroles jusque chez
vous d'accord alors on à valérie qui est
enseignante dans un lycée en seine et
marne ce sont les élèves qui nous happe
les cas positifs au niveau de
l'administration c'est le silence
puisque nous sommes en principe protégés
par les masques sauf que c'est
l'hécatombe dans le corps enseignant
beaucoup de collègues sont absents plus
aucune possibilité de remplacement
idem au sein de l'administration par
exemple dans mon lycée une secrétaire
positive a contaminé six de ses
collègues
pire encore les agents d'entretien sont
aussi touchés et là gros problème les
effectifs déjà restreint sont encore
réduits par les arrêts maladie nous
avons donc un problème de désinfection
des classes et ma copine kim explique
aussi que les cours de ps vont reprendre
sans masque en milieu clos et quelle
bonne idée
alors on va avoir d'autres témoignages à
vous nous en dire nous quand vous voyez
voilà ce que dit soumia déjà jimmy
mohamed est ce que vous vous êtes pour
fermer les écoles ou non les sons les
ouverte puisque à chaque fois qu'on a
demandé quelque chose le gouvernement
n'a pas tenu compte donc si je dis qu'il
faut pas les faire ils vont peut-être
finir par les fermer mais vous c'est
quoi votre conviction je suis perturbée
parce que quand on parle d'école on
oublie que c'est un ensemble qui est
très hétérogène
il faut qu on distingue deux choses les
enfants de plus de 10 ans jusqu'à 18 ans
et les moins de 10 ans je suis rendu
compte sur les quinze derniers jours que
l'incident c'est à dire le nombre de cas
qu'on va avoir
chez les 10 18 ans a doublé et que
finalement les enfants du primaire et de
la maternelle serait un peu plus
épargnées étant donné qu'on n'a pas su
mettre en place de vraies mesures de
protection à savoir des doublés des
classes permettre aux enfants de suivre
une scolarité plutôt normal puisque ce
qui revient en ce moment c'est que les
lycéens et les collégiens souffre de la
situation actuelle et ont beaucoup
souffert du premier confinement donc moi
je pense que étant donné que l'épidémie
n'est pas contre les chez les adultes et
bien forcément elle circule chez les
enfants donc ils vont fermer les herbes
et donc il faut fermer les écoles et
malheureusement quand on va fermer les
magasins
si on laisse les enfants ou à l'école
ils vont se contaminer et vont
contaminer les parents à la maison et
finalement on ne pourra pas contrôler
l'épidémie tant que l'épidémie ne sera
pas contrôlée dans les écoles et on va
devoir prendre des mesures
certainement plus difficile dans les
jours à venir m o di vizio fabrice moi
j'ai pas vraiment d'avis sur la question
c'est ce que j'ai dit en menant d'accord
préciser les choses non disons que
j'évite de parler tout le toutim
celui-ci ça mais je suis tombé là
évidemment c'est mon cabinet de rome qui
m'a envoyé ça qui m'a envoyé la plus
grosse étude jack est paru avant-hier
sur les écoles italiennes puisqu'ils ont
été analysés vraiment 97% des écoles
pour voir si les élèves étaient
contagieux paes qui avait hésité
responsable finalement est la conclusion
à laquelle arrive étude c'est que non la
conclusion mais je vous livre les choses
vraiment les décors ce décalage c'est en
dessous de 10 ans dans ce que disait
diminue en fait non il considère en fait
toutes les adolescents les ans par les
adolescents jeune j'aimais aucun avis
sur la d'accord pertinence de l'étude
et je vous dis que les scientifiques la
confé l'étude disent que c'est la plus
grosse étude jamais réalisée et qu'il
n'est pas possible de dire que la courbe
épidémique
en fait la reprise de cobaty munich est
liée aux élèves
babin gérard castet vous pensez qu'il
faut faire mais qu'est ce qui m'arrive
tout cas moi j'ai des enfants qui sont
au collège et au lycée comme géraldine
qu'on en parle que j'ai des retours des
parents d'élèves que j'ai des retours de
plein de gens et que visiblement c'est
une catastrophe totale que non seulement
les classes ferment moi c'est le cas
dans l'iss et de mon fils donc ça veut
dire que façon l'enseignement était
stoppée qu'il ya ceux qui s'arrêtent que
ce qui est diacre qui s'arrête pas il ya
des preuves qui sont malades ou qui a eu
un jour il ya cours un joli apa course
et il me semble après quand je lis un
peu tout ce qui se passe à paris en
banlieue parisienne et ailleurs ça me
semble être une catastrophe totale et je
préfèrerais qu'on dise aux élèves
oui on s'arrête un mois deux mois pour
essayer de d'éradiquer ou de freiner si
on bouge on préfère le mot mais moi de
ce que je vis alors à mon niveau ça en
vivent vraiment de l'intérieur dans
l'essai depuis celle un enfant de
partout non mais parce qu'effectivement
je vous fais moi je veux des français
c'est cette université il est partout
mais il a des enfants de partout non
mais il ya même des enfants la retraite
donc pour vous dire oui mais moi je
connais je balaye toutes les générations
est ce que vous dites une connerie c'est
pour être guéri comme m c'est bon c'est
bon merci mais si vous dites que je
m'excuse pas je m'exprime pas mais
dites-nous alors nos voix je les trouve
effectivement que bas et jusqu'aux os et
moi ça fait flipper savoir mes enfants
vont à l'école ce que j'ai envie qu'ils
ramènent le virus à la maison j'ai une
femme et un bébé en bas âge et ça me
fait flipper voilà si je vous fais chier
berne et je vous vois c'est délirant le
seul qui est censé ici pour l'instant
ses maîtres division nuit passée mais
ces deux là il fait dire bien sûr mais
bien sûr que non touche pas aux écoles
ça va être une génération sacrifiée
les enfants doivent pas payer pour nos
incompétences il faut vacciner il faut
vacciner les enseignants vacciner le
personnel
le vrai problème en collèges et lycées
c'est la cantine donc ouvrons des
gymnases pour que les enfants soient pas
masser à la cantine mais n'abandonnons
pas les enfants c'est insensé ce que
j'entends vous voulez benjamin castaldi
vous voulez qu'une génération d'enfants
dont les vôtres soit sacrifiée c'est ça
que vous voulez non mais sans - le roi
le début mais aujourd'hui il est arrêté
il ya ceux qui se continue les classes
fermées pas fermé c'est n'importe quoi
mes profs qui sont malades qui sont en
quarantaine mais vous avez peur sinon
les avait pas beaucoup de quoi on parle
mais pas d'enfant les enfants nés des
pensions alimentaires
jean messia mais je pense que la
contamination est très fort dans les
écoles parce que dans les cours de
récréation et c'est pas leur faute à
mais les gamins les adolescents eh bien
ils se mélangent les gestes barrière
c'est un petit peu relatif mais ça c'est
pas leur faute non plus et comme ça sa
terre cet âge là donc je pense que les
écoles ce en effet sont un foyer de
transmission le problème c'est que on
n'a pas le choix c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
seringue
en amont le gouvernement n'a rien fait
pour sécuriser des quantités de vaccins
nous permettant de déployer une
stratégie vaccinale pour freiner très
rapidement la pandémie et en aval nous
n'avons pas suffisamment lits de
réanimation pour traiter ce qui arrive
donc au milieu une mauvaise politique
entraîne forcément des mauvaises si vous
étiez au gouvernement là vous auriez
fait quoi fermer les écoles mais je
pense que là on va avoir les vacances de
pâques déjà j'aurais commencé par faire
une des vacances de pâques un peu
rallongé c'est dans une semaine avant et
ce même si c'est à dire pendant
voilà pendant un mois déjà on voit
comment ça marche mais là où je de
comptes gilbert désisté une génération
sacrifiée mais elle l'est déjà
parce qu'en réalité moi c'est pareil
j'ai des enfants le système scolaire
marche très très mal en cette fin des
classes fermées
là il ya une semaine brauner des pays au
monde elle a maintenu le dans le slalom
alors la fermeture des classes et le
confinement vers lequel de toute façon
on ne manquera pas d'aller mais un vrai
cette fois ci c'est uniquement dû à
l'impéritie du gouvernement qui n'a rien
prévu et n'a rien fait contrairement aux
autres pays comme la grande bretagne les
états unis même même des pays comme les
émirats ou comme le chili font mieux que
nous donc moi aujourd'hui sa république
en marche
franchement je me ferais très très
discret hgd daiichi n'est vous pétez la
violence oui et mode
moi je pense que fermer les écoles ça
doit être une usine une mesure vraiment
de dernière où ils vont le faire ou pas
vous êtes on est ce sera vraiment du
dernier recours et aujourd'hui ça ne
pensait pas demain aujourd'hui c'est pas
d'actualité on est un des pays au monde
qui a maintenu le plus les écoles
ouvertes
et si en fait c'est une fierté c'est une
fierté parce que maintenir les écoles
ouvertes c'est une mesure de justice
sociale c'est lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire
vous regardez ce qui se fait dans
d'autres telle mesure de ce nom mais je
termine dans d'autres pays où les écoles
sont fermées depuis des mois les cas de
décrochage sont absolument dramatiques
et pourquoi est ce qu'on a pu laisser
les écoles ouvertes parce qu'il ya eu
des protocoles sanitaires extrêmement
strictes porter dans les écoles et
là-dessus honnêtement il faut remercier
normandie je termine il faut remercier
des enseignants les chefs
d'établissements qui ont fait sa
renommée mais sans exercer une influence
indique tom et encore une fois c'est
très important de maintenir les
nouvelles générations d'après et ils ont
pas à payer ça les écoles vont rester
ouvertes a apparemment soumia qui je
vous dis pas ça dans la théorie c'est
parfait ce que sauf que dans la pratique
et les cas réels ça ne se passe pas du
tout comme ça les enfants enlèvent leurs
masques dans les cours d'école à la
comptine y sont extrêmement rapprochés
les enseignants sont contaminés par les
enfants rentrent chaque acompte
contaminés alors ça ne colle pas
évidemment
durée de tous ils ont été allongés ça
essaie de gérer avec sur le non mais les
auxerrois sur noir et vous parlez avec
des enseignants parce que moi oui elle
apparaît en tant que maire d'etagnac
genre avec des enseignes vous êtes j'ai
lu local le maire de cloche que je peux
moi avoir en tant que personne
particulière en tant qu'ami
d'enseignants en fait non c'est là je
suis désolé mais c'est la merde ça se
passe très bien les enseignements ne
sont pas plus confiné que le reste de la
population
franchement si sorte de preuve pas que
plus qu'on termine et je pense que c'est
inaudible pour les pays qui sont au
charbon qui sont en première ligne face
à des enfants qui sont contaminants qui
sont contagieux parfois même sans le
savoir symptômes c'est une des
particularité c'est que les enfants
peuvent transmettre le virus sans avoir
aucun symptôme
il dira aux enseignants vous inquiétez
pas tout va bien je pense que c'est
inaudible alors qu'on aurait dû se dire
qu'on peut aussi les remercier en les
vaccinant pas en avril après la guerre
il fera qu'on sera confiné mais bien
avant les voilà c'est celui là n'avaient
jamais depuis morissette on nous dis ça
depuis mon de plus en janvier puis en
février puis en mars la première
personne qui a été vaccinée puis en mars
et là on ne vous inquiétez pas en avril
et en avril on va le dire vous inquiétez
pas au mois de mai à bout d'un moment il
faut février dernier on avait déjà
proposé une petite fenêtre on était tous
prêts à subir un peu en filmant un peu
strict au moment où c'est un peu gérable
se dire que si on avait des vaccins
pourraient s'en sortir car on se rend
compte quand on regarde l'allemagne ils
ont confiné de façon extrêmement dure et
malheureusement l'épidémie repart de
façon exponentielle jusqu'à l'accident
le même temps mais on aurait pu se dire
qu'on ne parle pas d'arrêter l'école
pendant un an deux semaines de vacances
deux semaines où on prolonge et on remet
peut-être les compteurs à zéro pour
donner un peu de répit notamment
réanimation puisque derrière ce qu'on
oublie c'est qu'il va y avoir de nouveau
des déprogrammations et on parle des
cent mille morts dus qu'aux vide mais on
ne parle pas de tous ceux qui vont
mourir des conséquences du commises je
veux raconter une histoire en 20
secondes
dam d'un une la soeur d'un ami médecin
qui avait un cancer du sein l'année
dernière et ces examens ont été décalés
repoussé au fur à mesure elle a été un
peu désespérée elle a lâché d'affaires
elle avait 50 ans eh ben elle est morte
cette année de son cancer du sein parce
que finalement bien à cause de cette
politique est bien il ya des dommages
collatéraux et elle ne rentrera jamais
dans les statistiques
et on dira vous inquiétez pas on n'est
que cent mille morts on paiera 2 un
lourd tribut dans les mois ou dans les
années à venir
mais encore une fois je sais que c'est
difficile et on critique c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas souvent grand chose à
proposer
le salut viendra certainement d'un
confinement et de la vaccination qui
pour l'instant patine un peu
d'astrazeneca on en est où on en est
c'est la confusion la plus totale
allez dire au jour désormais de forbach
sina qu'astrazeneca quand un coup on
vous dit oui un coup vos dinan qu'est ce
qu'on fait de ceux qui ont les soignants
à qui on a demandé de se vacciner avec
astrazeneca des jeunes de 25 30 ans est
ce qu'ils vont avoir une seconde dose ou
pas c'est très confus je pense qu'il
faut restaurer la confiance savait
difficile de convaincre les gens
autrement moins les gens autour de moi
déjà il était un peu dans l'incertitude
en dix ans déjà c'est un vaccin de
seconde zone alors ne va essayer de
ramener en et vous inquiétez pas ça
marche et les études montrent que ce
vaccin est efficace 75 % d'efficacité
sur les formes de coronavirus et 100%
sur les formes sévères en revanche
maintenant on assistera d'effets
secondaires alors on nous dit que tout
va bien mais en même temps si tout va
bien pourquoi est-ce qu'on interdit aux
moins de 55 ans et leur fille un risque
ça c'est les gens le perçoivent comme ça
qu'on y arrive par 55 ans pourquoi moi
je prendrai ce risque ça devient très
difficile à la fois pour les médecins et
les gens je pense que le fait d'avoir
plus de files heures et de moderna et de
johnson & johnson ce sera peut-être un
salut on espère qu'on ira un peu mieux
gagnent moins que sur les écoles pour la
peste on avait les rats pour locaux
vides on a les enfants c'est de l'érable
à presque isle 21e siècle c'est comme
très étrange sont maintenant les enfants
qui nous contamine donc c'est le lieu à
éviter
sachant qu'on est passé par une phase où
le lieu des écoles était le paradis
c'est le seul endroit où on reste on
risque rien maintenant c'est le seul
endroit au risque que tout je crois que
il ya deux manières de voir les choses
soit vous mettez la lunette de
l'obsession du coc vide et voyez tout
par le prisme du coc vide il faut fermer
les écoles immédiatement soit on en a
assez de ce paradigme du coc vide de ce
qu vidéo centrisme et on essaye de
mettre d'autres lunettes et de regarder
les effets collatéraux du coc vide et
avec les autres lunettes qu'on a on est
saturé par les conversations sur le côté
le comité cette réalité on voit que les
enfants sont martyrisés chez eux
on voit que les enfants décrochent et
développe des idées de suicide ce qui
est quand même rare mais on a eu des cas
de suicides chez des enfants de moins de
15 ans et je crois que la seule attaque
la seule défense possible contre le coc
vide pour l'instant dans les écoles
c'est de continuer à y aller de
privilégier les aspects socio
psychologique des enfants par rapport à
la maladie
c'est dire que on est arrivé à un stade
maintenant on peut dire la chose
suivante qui était pas valable ya trois
mois que les effets du co vide mais ces
collatéraux du sco vides sont devenus
plus grave que les effets du co vis de
lui même et donc il ya ces pathologies
par exemple qui ne sont pas soignées
parce que quiconque n'a pas le comider
priés d'attendre que sa maladie nous
laisse tranquille pas le laisse
tranquille lui mais nous laisse
tranquilles nous donc il ya une maladie
aujourd'hui qui est la maladie à la mode
guînes maladie aujourd'hui qu'est la
maladie qui a toutes les priorités et si
vous voulez par cette obsession la part
ce lissage et par cette vision
nuno maniaque du virus on en oublie à
regarder quelque chose qui s'appelle
comment qui s'appelle la réalité alors
il ya beaucoup de gens qui lisent sur
les réseaux il faut laisser il faut
fermer les écoles les gens sont plutôt
on va voir les régions quadrillant si
beaucoup de gens disent il faut fermer
les écoles mais comment la réalité des
parents s'imaginent trois ados à la
maison c'est tous les deux jours on se
détester parce qu'il ya des claques
contactons faire mes classes à distance
y est les enfants ils n'en peuvent plus
ils sont là si au bout ils ont envie de
souffler après sur les enfants en bas
âge moi j'ai pas mal d'amis qu'on est
con des enfants qui sont jeunes cons 85
ans 6 ans faut aussi dire que pour les
parents ce un impact fort parce que
fermer des écoles qu'on se retrouve du
travail avec l'ordinateur dans la main
droite et le gamin dans la main gauche
je ne peux imaginer quand on est mère de
famille et qu'on doit gérer ça ce que ça
en jambes sur la vie au quotidien ils
conseilleront c'est extrêmement dur est
donc en fait maintenir les écoles
ouvertes c'est préserver la vie des
adultes
et puis encore une fois fort je
comprends alors je voulais tu mens ce
que vous avez dit un jour je suis aussi
aussi protéger les enfants c'est les
enfants c'est l'avenir du pays abritent
des bijoux et jean messieurs je vous ai
vu un petit peu ou pas voilà non non
c'est pas ça c'est que je vous avez vous
abordé mais star
il est tout cas l'un des deux chemins
comme toujours en fait n'avait pas hélas
créé pour l'aspect global et l'aspect
focal
finalement c'est un peu c'est un peu le
problème sur l'aspect global
moi je vous lis cette étude est la
première sortie en a pas d'étude plus
grosse pour l'instant elle sort d'où ça
elles sortent du territoire îlienne
grosses écuries italiennes sorti il ya
deux jours la gelée sur foi en dieu ou
en italien donc dents de devant le
manque d vie devant le manque de preuves
scientifiques des avantages de la
fermeture des écoles
le principe de précaution devrait être
celui de maintenir les écoles ouvertes
pour contenir les dommages graves encore
non mesurables scientifiquement
s'agissant et sans doute irréversible
s'est choisi honda celle de la santé
psychologique des enfants et des leurs
et de leurs familles
et ça c'est l'aspect global aspect
focale c'était là c'était pour ça moi je
voulais que j'avais accepté de venir
pour donner un cours témoignage sur
cette question de delà de l'école c'est
quelque chose que je connais assez bien
je suis père de famille bien combien
d'enfants dans trois cas là 18 18 16 et
15 en année les embrasse les embrassons
les divisions à droite la famille
division voilà aller et tout ça pour
dire que nous on était expats sur
quelques années et on s'est confronté
finalement à la difficulté de la
déscolarisation parce qu'on arrive en
plein milieu d'année machin est donc ça
n'a pas été simple simple est ce que je
voulais dire c'est que nous on a été
sous mes enfants étaient scolarisés par
le cned le temps qu'ils reprennent une
école dans le pays et sur le sur le
papier c'est vachement simple en fait
c'est vachement simple vous avez un
enfant des éducateurs qui sont géniaux
d'eads équipe vraiment dévoués c'est
super simple
la réalité c'est que je n'imaginais pas
le temps que ça prendrait c'est à dire
qu'en fait vous êtes derrière eux ils
étaient en primaire et au collège
vous êtes derrière eux mais quand je
vous dis derrière eux c'est toutes les
heures parce que le décrochage scolaire
il n'est pas une question de jours il
est une question d'heures en fait est
que ça peut être une machine infernale
qui finalement s'en va très très vite
quoi
et donc si vous voulez moi j'ai pas de
solution miracle j'ai pas joué les dj
pas j'ai pas d'avis sur la question
simplement ce que je dis c'est qu'il
faut faire attention parce qu'on risque
de renforcer une inégalité sociale
majeure parce que finalement les
familles aisées qui vivent dans des
fêtes dans des dents dans des maisons
dans des demeures ou que sais-je avec de
l'espace
c'est assez facile avec des parents qui
ont la possibilité d'aider les enfants
c'est assez facile mais ce que je peux
vous garantir d'expérience vous au
public pour certains enfants le lieu le
plus dangereux du monde c'est la maison
absolue et l'école est le lieu le plus
rassurant de la terre du chili c'est
vrai que voilà il ya ya ya ya ya ce
problème là aussi jean mais si à rennes
c'est à dire le problème laisser s'agit
pas de dire qu'il ya une solution est
idéale et l'autre qui ne l'est pas c'est
que personne ne veut fermer les écoles d
en manger les enfants restés à la maison
et mais là on est dans une situation
d'urgence
est-ce qu'il faut les fermer la grille
tout le monde à drulhe s'ils voulaient
rien entendre en tout état de cause rien
n'est plus important que la santé
j'entends la cause sociale j'entends la
mère de famille qui effectivement aura
ses enfants à côté d'elle avec
l'ordinateur ben c'est pas une situation
confortable mais entre ça et écrit
sentiment avoir un foyer infectieux
parce que c'est très important de savoir
que les enfants peuvent être
asymptomatique
donc ils peuvent transmettre le virus à
leurs parents les parents peuvent le
transmettre aux grands-parents voir les
enfants eux mêmes menacés un
grand-parent peut-on faire des symptômes
est nommé d'accord mais c'est encore une
fois c'est pas ces s'est passé pas si
simple je dis pas que la fermeture et
est la solution idéale mais encore une
fois lorsque la politique qui est suivi
est une politique inefficace
non on en est réduit en aval et
d'abandonner la page en effet un
solution inefficace et juste un dernier
mot quand j'entends délai la porte
parole de la république en marche nous
dire mais on attend que les vaccins
arrivent
excusez moi on l'a cru vous étiez au
gouvernement enfin dans d'autres pays on
est en train de tout ouvrir madame on
est en train d'ouvrir les terrasses au
sommet en allemagne en ce fonds mais la
comédienne nous comparer avec l'union
européenne
or la stratégie macro merkel c'est celle
de l'union européenne dont nous pas
causer conduit le monde le monde le
monde
ne se réduit à l'union européenne ne
serait pas la france et les états unis
vacciner énormément la grande-bretagne
d'accès notamment en réalité partout où
il ya des gouvernements qui ont suivi
des stratégies nationales on est en
train de tout ouvrir et revenir à une
vie normale dans l'est dans les endroits
du monde c'est à dire en france en
allemagne on a des gouvernements
progressistes et ben vous avez tout
foirer il est temps de le reconnaître
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent il
faut quoi il faut arrêter l'école tout
le mois d'avril profiter des vacances et
arrive à les faire à moi sont des côtes
sont menacées ce que vous pensez ah oui
je pense que ce serait effectivement une
mesure à prendre et qui pourrait être
efficace on a bien vu que le premier
confinement avaient quand même porté ses
fruits je vais rebondir quand même sur
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure par
rapport à la mère de famille qui a son
enfant en bas âge
à côté d'elle et pia son ordinateur
votre vision des choses me laisse penser
qu'en fait vous considérez l'école comme
une garderie
l'école est là pour que les parents
puissent travailler c'est quand même la
pression
vous parlez du décrochage scolaire est
pas vous dire que maintenir les écoles
ouvertes
oui mais il ya une occasion de l'ilsi
sociale et d'années quand même sous
jacente en fait l'école est là pour
garder les enfants
'cependant trouve que les parents
puissent travailler que j'ai dit c'est
[Musique]
aujourd'hui sauf un petit peu l'économie
française
si le télétravail vous savez que
maintenant tout le monde est pas sans
risque est ce que vous pensez
franchement tout le monde va passer en
tenant la majorité des télétravail enfin
n'y a quand même pas mal de gens
travaillent en panne on est quasiment
plus un téléphone non non vous laisse à
quasiment tous les ans travaille je lui
suis pas de quel métier vous parler
exactement le métro aujourd'hui
l'entreprise que je juge vous expliquer
c'est comment voulez vous que les gens
en télétravail arrive à s'en sortir
alors la question c'est est ce qu'il
faut différencier le primaire du
secondaire
ça c'est une vraie question parce que
les phares qui ment le secondaire les
anneaux ne se traite pas de la même
manière et je suis désolé sur les écoles
en général il ya plein de choses qui ont
été pleins de mesures qui ont été prises
sur les cantines dans les petites écoles
primaires justement pour éviter entre
autres je les entends souplesse et
regardez bien aujourd'hui
oui mais non pas dans la pratique si on
peut être de nattes et origines parce
que je voudrais voir on va voir le
chômage dans un sens vous pensez qu oui
comme ça on n'est pas dans un grand même
si on même si on applique le slogan du
gouvernement qui est à l'intérieur avec
les siens le problème c'est que les
enfants c'est le trait d'union c'est ça
qui fait le mélange et donc du coup
c'est impossible et ça ça se propage
guillaume bail à la théorie la pratique
en théorie évidemment tout ce qu'on
ferme a mathématiquement faire baisser
le nombre de contaminations donc c'est
bien
en revanche en pratique je trouve ça
dramatique de priver des enfants d'aller
à l'école des semaines voire des mois
mme oda raison vers celle à trois points
des décisions oui mais ils ont pas été à
l'école pendant deux mois à l'année
dernière c'est déjà énorme
moi mode a raison et vasseur aller aux
états unis ça fait un an que les écoles
les enfants sont pas scolarisés c'est un
drame
donc je trouve que priver les enfants
d'école pendant des semaines voir aussi
avec les trois fois durban non mais un
âge où on se construit en
intellectuellement et socialement là
c'est déjà beaucoup ils ont pas été à
l'école de mois l'année dernière donc je
pense que c'est enfin le dommage il est
mohamed
il faut arrêter un mois alors pas
malheureusement oui alors c'est vrai que
malheureusement oui
toute la semaine j'étais en consultation
pédiatrique du sommeil de l'enfant et
toutes les semaines
alors que d'habitude on a un an
d'attentats voire de voir des rangs des
rendez-vous les jambes ne viennent plus
en consultation alors les enfants que
j'ai pu suivre
eh bien tous se sont plaints de
l'absence d'écoles du premier
confinement donc il ya un impact en
revanche d'un autre côté quand
j'interroge des collègues autour de moi
on m'explique quand réanimation des gens
parlent de 50 ans un peu plus jeune
quand on leur explique parce qu'ils sont
conscients de ce qui va se passer
qu'on va devoir les endormir pour
l'heure m un tuyau dans la gorge et que
c'est le moment d'appeler leurs familles
eh bien ces gens là se mettent à pleurer
parce qu'ils disent que peut-être il ne
se réveilleront jamais effectivement
certains ne se réveilleront jamais moi
j'essaie pas d'attiser la compassion
vis-à-vis de ces gens là mais malgré
tout il ya une réalité actuelle c'est
que les gens meurent en réanimation le
nombre de lits de réanimation c'était
pas ça qui permet de contrôler
l'épidémie est une mesure d'urgence
d'affaires à prendre je pense que
malheureusement les écoles vont devoir
fermer comme d'autres commerces on a
fermé il ya aussi beaucoup
d'incohérences on va laisser ouvert les
coiffeurs on va fermer les
esthéticiennes expliquez moi pourquoi
important que les poils se laissait
szavay ce qui rend de temps
pourquoi les poils c'est disquaires
faut-il fermer les écoles oui à 67 % non
à 33% vrai